most of the people who have been paying
attention to um the better more
predictive
dissident narrative about public health
and covid
are having the sense of okay well
omicron swept in and it took the
pandemic out of the public health
tyrant's hands right it effectively
handed us something that couldn't be
controlled and wasn't killing very many
people
and that has brought us to a place that
feels like it could be the end of the
pandemic
now i will say
some people who are well positioned to
think about these things
have warned about what might emerge next
i don't yet know what to think about
that but let's just say
assuming that we do not have a next
variant that kicks this into some other
phase that we haven't yet thought about
right this does look like well
probably the end of something because so
many people are getting this um
vaccinated and not vaccinated that at
some level uh to the extent that natural
immunity is
a decisive factor right we're going to
reach herd immunity quickly because it's
racing through the population
[Music]
so with that said the point is all right
mandates are coming down because people
can see that mandates don't really make
any sense right what are you mandating
you're mandating a vaccine that doesn't
prevent people from contracting the
disease doesn't prevent them from
transmitting it doesn't reduce
viral load on what basis are you doing
that and they will say well because it
reduces hospitalizations well even if
that's true for young healthy people
that is no reason to mandate right are
you protecting me from me by locking me
in my house and firing me from my job
that doesn't seem like it's very likely
to actually be coherent right i also i'm
i'm kind of not feeling protected here
right maybe right so the point is the
the absurdity of the mandates and the
and you know really what it what has
happened
is that omicron has revealed what we
have been saying all along which is that
something else is driving this right
they swear it's being driven by a desire
to protect civilization and the point is
at the point that makes no sense they
still want to do it but
they still want to do it and um i know
you're going somewhere but i think this
is a good place to just show this um
i i i i saw this on twitter today zach
if you would show it nobody said you
wouldn't get covered if you're
vaccinated we keep on being told like
just you know
constant constant gaslighting by these
people
uh and so uh this this woman has um put
together just a few places where of
course they said that you wouldn't get
co-ed if you're vaccinated here we have
from joe biden on july 21st of last year
on cnn you're not going to get coveted
if you have these vaccinations
the director of the cdc on march 29th on
msnbc of last year vaccinated people do
not carry the virus don't get sick
fauci the niaid director on may 17th of
last year msnbc when people are
vaccinated they can feel safe they will
not be infected
and fauci again
of the vaccines on may 17th again last
year they're really really good against
variants
all of these things are untrue
some of these things were lies
right um i'm not gonna claim that biden
was lying i bet he just didn't know
um but
my god you know we and and we we keep
they keep on
changing what it is they're claiming
that they already said to us and if we
can't even keep track of that then of
course they're going to continue to win
and of course they're going to erect the
new people who they can claim okay yeah
well we got this wrong and we'll have a
couple of fall guys like well you know
we'll we'll make sure a couple of people
have their heads sort of metaphorically
cut off
and
and prop up some new people in the
positions that already existed with the
systems that already existed with all
the same incentives that already existed
you you got to slow down through that
because people are not going to
understand what's what's about to happen
here's the problem you've got
public health elites and whatever it is
that they represent
they have screwed up at uh an
unprecedented level they've effectively
crashed many of the functional systems
of planet earth they've caused untold
misery and frankly
untold disease i would suggest people
take a look at
john campbell's video from this week
talking about how many people actually
died of covet it's quite eye-opening
but he also talks about what people did
die of things like you know delays in
cancer diagnoses and things like this so
the point is this is an
unprecedented catastrophe
and the natural outgrowth of an
unprecedented catastrophe is a kind of
collective soul-searching in which we
figure out who screwed up
how it happened what system should have
been in place so it doesn't happen again
and we move forward in that way
but
were that to happen
these incredibly powerful many cases now
incredibly wealthy elites who earned so
much through this colossal error those
people have everything to lose if we
actually figure out what happened and
install the systems that would prevent
it from ever happening again
so they're now in search
of anything that can save them from
facing the people who were right
right
now what that means is that there's a
race that is
going to be kicking off here and we're
already seeing the first signs of it and
the race is for people who weren't right
all along who are now
going to
challenge the public health authority
they're right they're going to point out
just how disastrous so brave it's very
brave they're going to say
these public health officials failed us
but
and then they're going to attack those
of us who had this stuff right and the
idea is that the elites have an
incentive now to embrace this new middle
ground that is neither fish nor foul
right it is not on board with the public
health narrative it challenges it in
very strong terms but it also challenges
the dissidents who will be accused of
all sorts of defects and the point is
the elites have an interest in finding
that voice the struggle to phrase it
just so is now on and so people will be
falling all over themselves they will
some of them will know what they're
doing they're they're jockeying for
position in the new world order some of
them will not know what they're doing
they will just detect that suddenly
they're seeing articles on a particular
theme in all sorts of places and they
will think i could write that article
and they will write it and so you'll
have this whole new group of people in
the middle and their purpose
their purpose is to prevent meaningful
change right no no no that is the
utility that's not why they exist they
are taking advantage of an empty niche
and they will be adopted by um the the
mainstream and the elite in order to
serve the purpose of the elite right
well
let's just say the purpose of the niche
is that is to protect the elite from uh
a reckoning in light of what they have
done to yeah this is reckoning insurance
it's reckoning insurance but here's the
other thing there's another dimension to
this
which is there there are a huge number
of people in the audience who aren't
going to write that article they're not
going to write any article but they're
in a bad position right because to the
extent that for a year you've been brow
beating people for being on the wrong
side of history and then it turns out
they were on the right side of history
closer to two
uh
well let's just say there are people who
go back two years but we've been we've
been hearing these voices and the point
is if you're somebody who's been on the
wrong side of this and you were sure you
were on the right side of this and
you've been chastising people publicly
you've been shunning your friends and
all then the point is now you're in a
very awkward position that actually
mirrors the position of the elites who
want to stay in power right and so the
point is you've got a bunch of people
who will hunt for the best phrasing of
this narrative so that they can uh be uh
pulled up into the positions of power
that will decide what will be done and
what will be done is symbolic [ __ ] and
nothing more
right you've got an audience in search
of an excuse which is to say yes the
public health authorities did fail us
but those other people weren't right
right and you know you've got the elites
and their point is look anything so long
as it doesn't take us out of our
positions of power right that confluence
of those three is going to result in a
scramble that you're not going to see
coming and it's going to result in the
promise of reform and there will be no
reform and if you don't know what i'm
talking about
i would suggest you go watch the
excellent film
the big short
you want not one of the films i'm going
to recommend later but yes the big short
is a third film
it's it's a beautiful and heartbreaking
film and pay very close attention to the
end
right this is this is coming and we
could get in the road we could prevent
this but we have to be very careful
because the temptation to embrace these
people who have been outside of the fray
and are now going to rush in and they're
going to shout at the right people and
they're going to shout at the wrong
people and they're going to seem like
they're somehow more moderate and it's
nonsense it's strategic right
the people that you should be talking to
are people who took a risk and said what
needed to be said even when it was
almost impossible to do so
and
generated predictions based on an actual
understanding of the situation by
deriving
uh
deriving meaning from what we could see
from first principles as much as
possible i think frankly much of what
much of what i'm wrestling with at the
moment is god i mean as i told you like
there's a sadness that diverges into
rage
and i've just got this deep
disappointment with a lot of people
who i thought were honorable
and brave
and insightful and full of wisdom and
um
this has gone on long enough
and they have been
so many people have been
unwilling or incapable and it is often
hard to determine which it is
uh to actually investigate the evidence
in front of them and generate
uh a claim or an opinion that runs in
any way counter until like until
yesterday right like until the last
couple of weeks in the last month you
know like just about a year ago is when
we saw the loudly crumble in exactly
this way like this is just about a year
out from the loudly narrative crumbling
this way and suddenly there were a lot
of people going yeah but i was saying so
i was saying so
and
now that's just like this dull roar and
you know some fouchy and you know
barrack and all and dasik are still
denying it but it's it's you can see
that now without risking getting uh
kicked off youtube for instance um but
you still you can't you know we're still
demonetized we're still at risk for
talking about all the rest of the things
we're talking about and the people whom
i thought of as honorable and brave and
insightful and full of wisdom who have
said
nothing that counters the mainstream
narrative until like yesterday or not
even yet
and who are going to somehow contort
themselves into positions that make them
appear to have been carefully thinking
it through all along
when what has been revealed is actually
the
the white-coated scientism
thing
has confused most people who actually
don't understand what science is most
people who actually have never
thought of themselves as scientists or
done science or engaged with people
really truthfully honestly with the
people who are doing science
really have no idea and so they they
really feel like they have no ability to
assess the claims and so we have a whole
lot of people who have been claiming to
assess the claims who are actually doing
no such thing and so now the narrative
is crumbling and they're going to jump
up on top of that smoldering pile and
say aha yes here i am here i am like
what even are you standing on like
they're still going to be unable to
assess the claims that they're that
they're either now
saying
yes or true or no they aren't because
they've revealed throughout this that
again they're either unwilling or
incapable of doing so well
we're going to have to
do a better job of sorting because
they're going to be very various
different categories of people
hat
well
i would say that there are certain
heuristics right it is now going to
become
profitable to find that middle ground
position of course so you don't know
anybody who adopts it now why they're
adopting it right you do not have
evidence that they have you know if if
you get slightly ahead of the narrative
now but it ends up being a huge win then
the point is okay well what is that
right i think that was you promoting
yourself i don't think that was you
actually you know figuring it out so the
question is what is this on the other
hand the scales will fall from people's
eyes more and more rapidly right right
and so
it's
a very different realm but i found uh i
adopted a policy
um
for people who came to me this happened
somewhat regularly and people came to me
after uh the evergreen thing
and apologized right
and they said you know what i gotta tell
you i did not know what was going on i
called it backwards and i'm so
embarrassed and i would say
you know what
you don't owe me an apology and here's
why
when you figured it out you did the
right thing right anybody who does the
right thing upon discovering what it
actually is
we're square and i think we need to
adopt this policy generally but the
right thing
includes
not pretending that you always felt this
way
or that you were really on the side and
you you're like i'm going to dig up
something that i said or wrote or
tweeted you know once six months ago in
a sea of things like
no that's not the right thing that's
cheating and you know it you know it
right so
you've got a being honest about the fact
that you've changed your position is
fundamental right doing the right thing
and the right thing does not mean just
wagging your finger at the people who
screwed this up so badly it means not
wagging your finger at the people who
got it right right
that's that's also part of the right
thing 100 fundamental
and you know then the question is
and this is the tough part i think we
need to figure out
how to feel
about the various different categories
of people
right
so i don't want to get too far in the
weeds here but obviously feeling
is a
proxy for stuff right we feel because
it's a quick way of actually deploying a
you know game theoretic approach that
has been refined by selection and it's
not very
um
properly applied to many modern
circumstances so for example
um if you imagine yourself a thousand
years ago
in some circumstance where some person
delivers you a terrible insult if you're
a man let's say and some person delivers
you no
we're clear on that but um if somebody
delivers you a terrible insult
suggesting that you are you know a weak
person
it might be important that you throw a
punch
because if you don't it might imply that
the person was actually accurate and it
might result in you facing a lot of uh
bad stuff going forward on the other
hand in modern times if you're
in a bar
500 miles from home and some person that
you've never seen and will never see
again says something insulting the game
theory is very different but you still
have the same emotional reaction
[Music]